mr cassian andor himself i feel like no
one is more excited to be here than you
definitely i've been working on this
show for a long time uh
you know when i when i did rogue one i
thought that was it i thought this i
mean that was it in terms of cassian
under in my life and suddenly i got this
opportunity and it's been yeah three
years three years and a half of working
in this uh obviously
the pandemic didn't make it any easy
and uh and we're finally ready to share
this with the audiences and uh and
and in a
in this format that allows us uh you
know
to explore so much you know it's so rich
for an actor these
long format where we have 12 episodes
you know to tell a story so i'm blessed
i'm i'm a really happy actor you know
that's exciting you know the the casting
we meet at the beginning of the series
is different than the one we know and
love in rogue one right totally the idea
is that the that uh we tell you what
needed to happen in his life
uh to make him aware of what he was
capable of you know and i think it's
very important to remind people that we
are all capable of doing extraordinary
things
but sometimes we forget you know and
also we're all capable of being part of
something bigger because how they're
someone thinks like us you know and it's
about
it's about accepting that we are who we
are and uh that
we
we have the
the power of being part of change if
if we decide and this story is about
that awakening you know so let's see
what people think about it that's
amazing thank you so much so nice
meeting you